Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, unsere kleine Welt und hier bin ich wieder, Tim, nach einer Sommerpause, die einfach mal dringend nötig war.
Ist jetzt ähm ist es mal wieder so weit und Zeit äh vor allem hier
in Korona-Fragen wieder einzusteigen. Denn wenn der Drosten schon nicht äh Podcast sind, dann muss jetzt so ein bisschen die Meterebene liefern. So, erstmal sage ich, hallo zu Pavel, der ist natürlich auch dabei.
Ja, hallo Tim.
Moin. Ja, Pavel, wie ist dir denn, äh, im Sommer so ergangen.
Ja, ich ähm äh habe fleißig jeden Tag äh so meine Zahlen.
Aktualisiert. Ich mache es immer noch von halb von Hand, sage ich mal, auch äh.
Weil ich halt jeden Tag gerne auch selber einen Blick drauf werfen möchte, ob das alles passt und äh um auf dem Laufenden zu bleiben und ja äh,
große Them.
Bezahlen aktualisieren, meinst du natürlich deine tolle Kurve, Risiko Deutschland nach Lindnern und Kreisentabelle. Das sollten wir,
der Stelle nochmal äh erwähnen. Ähm ja, die sich jetzt äh technisch nicht mehr groß verändert hat. Sie ist ein bisschen schneller geworden, habe ich so den Eindruck.
Äh ein kleines Softwareupdate, also lädt nicht mehr so lange, aber im Prinzip nach wie vor die Aufstellung nach,
Landkreisen, mit äh ein paar statistischen Auswertungen auf Basis der RKI-Zahlen, um zu sehen
was denn eigentlich so äh los ist in Deutschland, insbesondere in den einzelnen Landkreisen natürlich
und um so ein paar Messzahlen zu haben, woran man sehen kann, ob wir denn jetzt hier irgendwie wieder kurz vorm vor der Apokalypse äh stehen oder,
eben nicht, ne.
Was ich, was ich noch ist, ich habe ein bisschen noch äh weiterentwickelt an der Version zwei, die liefert mir jetzt äh.
Mal Zeit rein für alle Kreise,
ähm Länder und äh fürs gesamte Land und zwar äh Zeitreihen, die halt genau mit
demübereinstimmen, was das RKI jeden Tag an Zahlen so vermeldet, also das sagen passt äh jetzt und ähm,
ja, da müsste ich noch ein paar Tage jetzt reinstecken, um ähm diese ganzen Zeitreihen dann irgendwo auch mal äh ne,
anzuzeigen. Im Moment benutze ich die, um dann wiederum meine Grafen zu aktualisieren, das heißt, das spart mir halt schon so ein bisschen äh Zeit, weil
ähm ja, sonst hatte ich immer mir die Zahlen aus der Wikipedia rausgeholt, dass setzt aber auch ein bisschen Müdigkeit ein, offenbar da äh hinkt es manchmal auch um paar Tage, manchmal um eine Woche hinterher, das heißt, äh jetzt
musste ich dann sagen, äh selber aktualisieren, habe, dann muss dann teilweise auch immer ins Internetarchiv äh reingehen vorher, um mir da die Zahlen rauszupicken und.
Jetzt äh ja hole ich die äh extra hier ich die halt komplett äh aus den Daten,
umsetzen, äh die das RKI zur Verfügung stellt. Das.
Mhm. Version zwei null saß er.
Ja, ja, also.
Ich lese hier noch Version null neun vierzehn. Wo ist jetzt die Version? Eins geblieben.
Ja, ja, ja, also ähm mit zwei ist dann wirklich sozusagen neuer äh Riefereit, der äh wo die Basis, wo die Zahlen bisschen anders ermittelt werden, als ich das vorher gemacht habe
vorher, äh beziehungsweise so, wie es jetzt noch auf dem Risc Server ist, die Zahlenstimmen halt nicht
hundertprozentig mit den LKI-Zahlen überein, weil ich da äh eben immer geguckt habe, was es neu dazugekommen.
Dann sagen versucht habe, sagen einen kompletten konsolidierten Datensatz, der halt äh auch die Daten enthält, wann.
Die veröffentlicht werden, die die Zahlen äh sozusagen Eingangsstempel beim RKI
aber weil sich ja die Daten ändern sich halt teilweise von einem Tag auf dem anderen und um das sagen, um auf die gleichen Zahlen, wie das RKI zu kommen
habe ich jetzt einen gewaltigen Datensatz, der besteht aus allen,
vom RKI veröffentlichten Daten und man kann da halt nichts wegschmeißen, sondern muss, muss die halt komplett nehmen, das ist natürlich ein ziemliches Monster, aber äh ja, damit funktioniert's dann.
Ja gut, also du hast dich auch die ganzen Sommer über mit diesen Zahlen beschäftigt, höre ich jetzt so ein bisschen raus.
Ja, ich habe da immer, ich habe da einen Blick äh halten im Auge drauf gehalten, um einfach auch natürlich selber zu wissen, was geht da gerade vor und habe dann so auf Twitter, so im Prinzip so an
einmal die Woche oder einmal alle zwei Wochen dann mal ein paar aktualisierte Grafen veröffentlicht.
Ja, wir hatten ja noch, als wir, glaube ich, noch das letzte Mal auf Sendung waren, hatten wir vor allem.
In Berlin sonst zwischen Piek, wobei auch äh.
Ja, das war so Mitte Juni eigentlich gegen die Zahlen ja schon mal plötzlich äh sehr bedenklich hoch, sowohl sowohl.
Im Bund und noch krasser in Berlin. Äh haben sich dann aber,
so aus unklaren Gründen ganz schnell wieder normalisiert und gingen dann wieder,
runter die nächsten drei Wochen, um dann jetzt die letzten zwei Monate äh wiederum anzusteigen. So.
Also jetzt die vermeldeten äh Neuinfektionen, meine ich. So, das heißt, dass an dieser berühmte R Wert.
Seit eigentlich sechs, sieben Wochen äh im Bund eigentlich permanent über eins liegt.
Ja und so ist es halt.
Bis äh heute im Bund, ähm um die eins Komma zwei äh so der Ehrwert, das heißt,
pro Woche hatten wir halt jetzt dann einen eigentlichen exponentiellen Anstieg so, wobei wenn man sich die Kurve anguckt, ist es eine sehr flache Kurve, fast
Linear könnte man sagen, wobei es eine sind einen leichten Bauch hat, aber was in dem Zeitraum
auch passiert ist, äh ist, dass die Tests weiter ausgeweitet wurden in den, in den letzten Wochen, so Testregime wurde also mal wieder geändert. Das heißt, alle Zahlen sind auch wieder.
Äh wie immer mit Vorsicht zu genießen, weil immer, wenn sich das Testregime ändert. So passieren natürlich Dinge mit den Neuinfektionen und in dem Fall.
Äh sind.
Ja, sehen die neue Infektion durch die angestiegenen Testzahlen äh schlimmer aus, als sie eigentlich sind, wobei äh ähm jetzt nicht nur die Zahl der Tests angestiegen ist, sondern auch
Der Anteil der positiven Tests, insofern liegt es jetzt nicht nur,
an der Ausweitung der Tests, die gestiegenen Zahlen, sondern diese wirklich was,
dazugekommen an an Infektionen, aber,
sagen die die Wahrheit äh liegt irgendwo dazwischen, also zwischen dem, was wir an Zahlen sehen und,
ähm ja ähm also der Anstieg ist geringer. Auf jeden Fall als äh uns das die Reihenzahlen jetzt äh suggerieren durch ihn.
Blick jetzt hier gerade auf deine äh Grafik, die wir auch in ins äh äh Block stellen. Ich wollte gerade nochmal kurz sagen, ähm hatte ich nämlich, glaube ich, am Anfang vergessen. Wir haben den zweiundzwanzigsten August.
Zwanzig zwanzig. Also wir haben jetzt fast seit zwei Monaten keine Sendung gemacht.
Und ähm ich meine, die Grafik, die quasi jetzt immer mit den Sendungen zuletzt äh mit veröffentlicht wurde, also deine, dein eigener Plot
darüber, was sozusagen das von dir nachgerechnete R so ist, da sind ja dann mehrere Kurven drin, also du hast jetzt irgendwie ein
den RKI, den geglätteten, offiziellen RKI äh Erwerter, als Vergleicht, du hast deinen selbst ausgerechneten, ne.
Mhm. Mhm.
Mhm. Der, ja, genau, der wiederum ja, also die drei verschiedenen äh geglätteten Erwerte ist äh wie gesagt, einmal hatte ich angefangen mit einfach die äh normalen.
Erwerte für die letzten sieben Tage und dort den Durchschnitt genommen. Das sozusagen eine Variante, um einen sieben Tagesart zu machen, dann das Glättungsverfahren.
Vom äh RKI, die erst den Mittelwert nehmen und äh dann auf Basis der gemittelten.
Werte, äh, dann R berechnen und dann habe ich noch selber einen relativ,
einfaches Verfahren, indem ich,
äh die Zahlen der letzten sieben Tage nehme und äh die der sieben Tage davor und ins Verhältnis hetze und davon die Wurzel ziehe und das ergi.
Eben auch so eine Art äh RW. Ähm.
Ich habe extra diese drei verschiedenen drin gelassen, um so ein bisschen auch die Unschärfe der Rechnungen äh klarzumachen,
sich diese Werte doch je nachdem, wie man Mittel bereits doch sehr äh stark ähm oder.
Zwar ungefähr alle dann doch den Trend anzeigen, aber höher oder tiefer äh ausschlagen oder schneller, das heißt äh ja, diese Erbe Rechnungen ähm äh sind halt,
sehr abhängig von der Rechenmethode, wenn man dann einen einen Er nennt und ähm mit den Dreien kann man dann so in etwa sehen, wo in welchem Bereich äh sich
äh der geglättete sieben Tage R Wert tatsächlich befindet und da liegen wir halt um die eins Komma zwei herum jetzt
fünf Wochen bisschen ging ein bisschen drauf, bisschen runter, also auf Bundesebene.
Also was man den der Grafik damit
ansehen kann, dass zunächst einmal, also diese Ehrwerte, okay, die haben jetzt Unterschiede, aber jetzt mal so richtig jetzt gerade über so einen langen äh Zeitraum, du erfasst es ja im Prinzip jetzt seit äh knapp Mitte März. Äh wenn man sich anschaut, so,
die Decken mehr oder weniger schon so denselben Trend ab, ne? Also die die
Details sind sozusagen äh kann man, kann man fast ignorieren, wenn ich fast sagen. Ähm das korrigiert natürlich dann entsprechend mit dem Infektionsgeschehen, also
Klar, darauf basiert das Ganze ja auch, aber was jetzt hier vollkommen aus dem Ruder läuft, ist ja die Zahl, die der gestorbenen.
Also, hat mir das am Anfang noch so, dass eigentlich die Zahl der gestorbenen Menschen mehr oder weniger mit so einem zwei, drei Wochen Zeitverzug hinter dem eigentlichen Infektionsgeschehen hinterherläuft, hat sich,
schon vor ja schon Anfang Juni.
Irgendwie voneinander entkoppelt, also weder dieser Pik, den du vorhin erwähnt hast, der dann äh diese ganze Turniere ist, Fleisch äh Industrie, äh da kam mir auf einmal hohe Zahlen bei raus.
Weder das hat irgendeine äh Folge gehabt, noch eben das jetzt seit längerer Zeit angestiegene Infektionsgeschehen.
Wie erklärst du dir das.
Hier, also mein bisschen ein leichter,
peace, äh, ein leichter Anstieg war vor zwei Wochen da, bei der Zahl der Toten, aber dann seitdem
ist es auch wieder runtergegangen, das heißt, in der Tat äh sieht man da kaum Korrelationen zwischen den beiden äh Dingern und gut meine Erklärung ist,
ähm ist wahrscheinlich mehrere Faktoren sind, die da zusammenkommen. Das eine ist das Testregime, das veränderte.
Ähm, das heißt, wenn wir mehr testen, kriegen wir natürlich auch absolut äh
mehr Fälle einfach äh verringern dann letztlich die Dunkelzifferquote äh durch mehr, testen, aber ähm da das nirgendwo erfasst wird, sondern wir nur auf die nackten Zahlen gucken,
äh nehmen die zu. So, gleichzeitig ähm sind.
Auch wohl vermehrt äh jüngere äh Personen jetzt erkrankt, das spielt dann auch,
eine Rolle, so, weil die in der Regel halt nicht sterben oder viel weniger sterben
das äh äh kommt auf jeden Fall auch rein, ja ähm wahrscheinlich die beiden wesentlichen Faktoren Plus, es könnte.
Äh auch,
sein, dass man bisschen mehr Erfahrung mit der Behandlung hat und vielleicht das Virus auch ein bisschen weniger tödlich geworden ist, so. Das könnte da alles mit hineinspielen, äh
Und ja, in der Tat können wir feststellen, bisher, dass.
Ähm ja, zwischen, dass die, der Anstieg, der der Infektion, äh, die sich der Neuinfektion, die sich ungefähr verdreifacht haben in den letzten acht Wochen,
Das können wir von der Zahl.
Toten äh nicht sagen. Die haben sind zwar auch, wie gesagt, zwischenzeitlich wieder angestiegen. Es waren mal weniger. Das heißt, ein bisschen ist ist schon da, aber es ist nicht ja, so sicht.
Ja, wir wir reden ja auch von von äh unter zehn pro Tag, wenn ich das richtig sehe, ne? Also es ist relativ niedrige Zahl.
Das kommt halt auch noch dazu, dass wir sonst in einem relativ niedrigen Zahlenregime bewegen.
Ja, also was die mögliche
was diese Aussage betrifft, dass der Virus unter Umständen nicht mehr so tödlich ist. Also da habe ich sehr viel Widersprüchliches zugefunden. Ich glaube, die These vertritt so derzeit noch keiner so richtig. Das kann natürlich irgendwie sein, aber ähm.
Wenn ich das richtig sehe, sind jetzt auch noch nicht so viele äh Mutationen äh festgestellt worden. Ich denke.
Man kann zumindest derzeit davon ausgehen, dass es wirklich etwas damit zu tun hat, dass ich eben das Virusgeschehen mehr,
in die jungen Leute quasi in den jüngeren Altersbereich verschoben hat.
Wobei ich mich natürlich dann frage, okay, äh waren die vorher noch nicht.
Betroffen, so sind nun mal eben die aktiven in der Gesellschaft, die die äh sich viel treffen, die viel Unternehmen wollen und irgendwie auch etwas schwieriger an die Leine zu nehmen sind. Ich glaube, am Anfang waren halt einfach.
Noch überhaupt gar keine Schutzmechanismen am Start für die Älteren und besonders Betroffenen und die haben sich mittlerweile ganz gut weggekrümelt und äh gut verbarrikadiert und werden vielleicht auch besser geschützt, et cetera
klar, dann hast du gesagt, Behandlungsmethoden im Krankenhaus, dazu haben wir jetzt überhaupt gar keine Zahlen, da kann man jetzt nur ein bisschen mutmaßen, was dazu dabei trägt. Ähm,
aber ähm trotz alledem ist jetzt eben die Verbreitung des Virus lässt sich halt so richtig äh derzeit nicht stoppen. Und ich frage mich, inwiefern jetzt eben da der, der Sommer auch seinen Beitrag geleistet, weil wir hatten ja so ein bisschen die Hoffnung
ja, alle im Freien und so weiter, ein bisschen Abstand hält, dann passt das schon und dass uns hier nicht so richtig bewahrheitet.
In Berlin äh
kam auch vom Gesundheitsämtern die Meldung, dass rund die Hälfte der Neuinfektionen
ähm importiert sind, das heißt, äh das sind überwiegend Urlaubs, also die Hälfte der Neuinfektionen sind bei Urlaubsrückkehrern aufgetreten, die sich im Urlaub angesteckt haben.
Und das sind dann natürlich auch vor allem aktivere, jüngere Menschen und äh gewesen, die halt äh jetzt in den letzten Wochen.
In den Urlaub gefahren sind und sich dann, ja, im Urlaub, Corona eingefangen haben.
Äh, wie gesagt, sogar, also die Hälfte äh laut,
ähm laut Gesundheitsamt vor ein paar Tagen kam die Meldung. Ja ähm.
Was machen wir da jetzt draus.
Ja, also.
Gut zwei Dinge jetzt im Hinblick auf die Zukunft oder was kann man da an Prognosen rausziehen. Ich meine, das eine ist irgendwann.
Wird sich die Zahl der Tests auch wieder.
Äh stabilisieren, wenn sich das neue Testregime eingerängt hat, ist ja noch nicht so ganz passiert, also was ja
im Wesentlichen passiert ist es, dass man gesagt hat, okay, Rückkehrer müssen getestet werden. Da gab's ja dann in Bayern auch den, diesen Skandal, weil man hat zwar getestet, aber dann wurden die Tests ja
irgendwie.
Die Ergebnisse nicht zugestellt oder die Tests nicht ausgewertet. Also nicht also jedenfalls waren da plötzlich äh mehrere tausend.
Eine zigtausend Teststil in Bayern gemacht wurden, blieben aber Ergebnislos, einschließlich mehrere tausend infizierte, die man da plötzlich hatte, die dann nicht benachrichtigt worden.
Sind oder extrem verspätet benachrichtigt worden sind, die halt
Prinzip erst davon erfahren haben, dass sie infiziert sind, als sie wahrscheinlich schon wieder äh genesen waren oder nicht mehr ansteckend, also mit teilweise ein, zwei Wochen Verspätung erst davon erfahren haben. Und das ist natürlich
ziemlich suboptimal und in Berlin hat wohl das Gesundheitsamt gerade auch kapituliert und gesagt, ja.
Nee, also mit den ganzen äh.
Tests die da an den Flughäfen gemacht werden, gerade mit der Anzahl äh kommen wir jetzt gerade auch nicht klar und äh kriegen das irgendwie auch nicht geregelt. Und äh ja.
Alles ein bisschen traurig, muss man sagen, weil ist ja nicht so, als wenn das alles jetzt so überraschend passiert wäre und äh.
Dass die Leute überraschend in den Urlaub gefahren und überraschend wieder zurückgekehrt sind davon. Ja, also das das ist schon so ein bisschen
äh ja, Armutszeugnis, eigentlich ihr, aber wenn man sagen, es ist jetzt nicht offenbar nicht nur Berlin, sondern auch Bayern, ähm, so,
hier eigentlich immer gerne Musterschüler sein möchten und gut vielleicht in vielen Bereichen auch sind, aber in dem Fall.
Ähm offenbar auch nicht besser, ja.
Vielleicht sind sie aber auch einfach geographisch benachteiligt, das muss man natürlich auch sagen, ne? Also gerade so äh zur Urlaubszeiten ist natürlich die Lage so an Österreich, Schweiz, äh.
Äh et cetera dran ist, selber in den Urlaubsziel, also von daher.
Dieses äh habe mir den Virus aus dem Urlaub geholt, so es es wird natürlich der Virus auch hin getragen, ne? Und das das muss man auch nochmal äh mit einberechnen.
Ja, ja, das ist das nicht nur, nicht nur, wie ich von zu Hause geholt, sondern natürlich bringen auch äh Besucher, äh, den Virus mit, wobei das sicherlich für Berlin,
äh sogar noch eher in vermehrten Maße gilt. Äh wobei gut, was dort passiert ist, man hat's halt zwar geschafft.
Massenweise Leute zu testen in Bayern, aber der Rest der Kette hat dann nicht funktioniert. War halt dann haufenweise Tests, die dann zum Teil sogar, ja,
die Labore haben sogar ausgewertet, aber man hat Zeit dann nicht mit nicht hinbekommen, äh die Testergebnisse den Leuten zu übermitteln, ja. So, das war das Problem.
Ja, vielleicht so den Test, also was mich da so ein bisschen verwundert ist, dass wir eigentlich immer noch so in dieser äh Domäne der PCR-Tests äh feststecken. Das hätte er nun eigentlich ähm ich hätte jetzt eigentlich erwartet, dass,
mehr Schnelltest verfügbar werden und zum Einsatz gebracht werden.
Ist mir nicht so richtig klar, warum das eigentlich nicht der Fall ist, denn es gibt ja diese Tests, also die sogenannten Antigentests, die halt.
Nicht so zuverlässig sind, wie der PCR-Test, aber die eben den großen Vorteil haben, dass sie eben in sehr viel, sehr viel einfacher, also bittiger sind, schneller äh angewendet werden können, et cetera.
Und so eine Massenverfügbarkeit von solchen Testzeit, ehrlich gesagt, so ein bisschen erwartet für diesen Zeitpunkt
scheint aber nicht der Fall zu sein. So hängen wir dann halt auch immer noch so ein bisschen in dieser Logik. Das äh Test sind jetzt hier so eine hauptamtliche Tätigkeit und da müssen
Ärzte und Labore in Bewegung gebracht werden. Was ja vollkommen okay ist, wenn man jetzt für sich wirklich mal sicher sein will, aber ich sehe nicht so richtig den Trend hin zu
die war mal alles permanent mit etwas weniger Zuverlässigkeit testen, dann wird schon genug bei hängen bleiben, um insgesamt die Sache ein wenig in den Griff zu bekommen.
Also an sich sollten.
Ja, schnellen Tests jetzt mittlerweile verfügbar sein, wo dann äh innerhalb von einigen Minuten um das Ergebnis äh.
Vorliegen müsste, ist mir auch nicht ganz klar, woran's da hapert. Jetzt.
Ich direkt plus, dann gibt's noch das Zwischen, die nicht glaube, es gibt auch so mittlerweile mh Maschinerien.
Oder Maschinen, die auch direkt dann vor Ort innerhalb von, wie sagt man.
Weiß nicht in einer Stunde oder so, nach einer halben Stunde ein Testergebnis liefern können. Also es ist jetzt keine Tests für zu Hause,
die wie ein Schwangerschaftstest funktionieren, sondern sind wir ja so eine Kombination aus Maschine und äh ja
geht, aber dann sollte dann trotzdem schnell gehen und das ist in einigen Ländern äh im Einsatz. Ich habe dann auch gehört, in der Türkei scheint es auch recht gut
zu funktionieren, dass die Leute dort, äh, wenn ihr am Flughafen oder so testen, innerhalb von eins, zwei Stunden ihr Ergebnis äh haben, so.
Das ist mir unklar, warum das hier nicht gehen sollte und ähm weil eigentlich müsste es auch möglich sein, innerhalb von äh zwei oder drei Wochen,
ein Labor einzurichten am Flughafen, ja, direkt dort. Und äh wo die Proben dann dire.
Verarbeitet werden sitzt, wenn man's mit klassischer PCR macht. Also,
ja, da scheint mir auch so ein bisschen ja, an manchen Stellen so die Luft raus zu sein, dass als bisschen sich ja Resignation eintritt oder man's ein bisschen schleifen,
lässt, gerade, weil äh das nicht mehr so katastrophal akut erscheint. Das spielt wahrscheinlich auch eine Rolle.
Ja gut, es scheint nicht mehr so katastrophal akut zu sein, im Sinne von äh man geht raus, wenn man das sofort infiziert und dann muss man da auch gleich sterben. Ne, also das ist so ein bisschen äh weg und das mag auch zu diesen Zahlen, also als solche so ein bisschen
beitragen, ne? Da ist einfach diese Bedrohlichkeit dieser Situation nicht da ist. Aber auf der anderen Seite muss ich sagen, gibt's ja schon
konkrete Auswirkungen, die einfach ja
sich auch so ein bisschen festsetzen. Also während ich jetzt auch gerade durch dieses Gespräch mit dir regelmäßig,
ja, dass man sich einfach mal beschäftigt, äh Podcast machen, la la la, man nimmt die Situation jetzt an und und haut sich die ganze Zeit Wissen und Nachrichten rein, dann ist man ja irgendwie beschäftigt und dann war's.
Für mich relativ okay, äh damit sagen wir mal so die allgemeine Bedrohlichkeit, dieser Situation, auch so ein mental, ein bisschen auszublenden.
Ja, war dann so
ist irgendwie jetzt eine Phase, lockt down, ja, wird auch wieder alles anders werden. Optimismus, mhm, alles wunderbar. So. Und gewisser Hinsicht hat das ja auch stattgefunden. So, aber jetzt ähm,
wacht man dann im äh auf, in so einer neuen Situation, gut neu ist, vielleicht nicht das richtige Wort, aber so in, in einer in einem Resultat dieses ganzen Geschehen, wo man sagt, okay, also
ist jetzt immer noch nicht so richtig absehbar. Wann hier vielleicht eine medizinische Lösung gefunden werden kann, also eine pharmakologische, sprich Impfstoff, ja, also.
Zeichnet sich ja ein, einiges ab. So, nur Wissen ist halt was anderes. Und ich denke mal, ich treffe auch so deine Einschätzung.
Wenn ich sage, der Winter wird wahrscheinlich nochmal komplett.
Im Chorona-Regime abgefeiert werden müssen, so. Sprich, das nächste halbe Jahr.
Wird weiterhin von dieser Situation dominiert sein.
Und dann ändern sich natürlich die Parameter, ne? Dann sind wir eben nicht mehr draußen im Freien und kann mal eben so einen Campingurlaub äh einwerfen, sondern äh alles läuft weiter äh
Business, Wirtschaft schaffe, schaffe, äh Schulen, et cetera, pp. Und dann wird's halt kalt und dann will man halt wieder
äh rein und dann stellt man auf einmal fest, so hoppala. All die ganzen Dinge, mit denen man sich dann so in der dunklen Jahreszeit auch äh gut ablenken kann, sind nicht da.
Ja, Kino, wer geht da schon hin? Theater, na ja, bestenfalls Notbetrieb. Ähm Clubs.
Und überhaupt nicht mehr. Ja, also so Tanzveranstaltungen aller Art einfach äh weg, komplett. Ähm und Kneipen.
Genau dasselbe Drama. Leute werden nicht in die Kneipe gehen. Also ein paar werden's natürlich tun, so. Äh.
Und da kann man nur sagen, good luck. Und Corona Warn-App, bitteschön, aber.
Ähm ein Zulauf wird's dann nicht geben. Das heißt, da werden dann halt auch entsprechend einerseits wird's wirtschaftlich für diese Bereiche halt äh.
Weiterhin schwierig sein, also ist ja schon schwierig, wird auch schwierig äh bleiben. Manche dann vielleicht auch erstmal so richtig noch den Todesstoß äh versetzen, aber es fällt es fehlt dann sozusagen die Beschäftigung.
Und das, das wird dann doch schon ein Problem. Und,
mir macht das jetzt insofern ein bisschen Sorgen, dass dann halt einfach dieses ganze äh Testregime weiter so in diesem Business ist Yussuf gemacht wird,
und nicht ähm in irgendeiner Form eine neue Kreativität entsteht, wie man denn jetzt diese Phase auch gut ähm ja, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes überwintern kann.
Also, ja, da ist sicherlich jetzt ja, sind Ideen gefragt, so ein paar habe ich da auch äh gehört schon, aber vielleicht nochmal zum Risiko,
ähm vermutlich ist aktuell das Risiko.
Sich anzustecken für die meisten in Deutschland lebenden Höher, als es äh je zuvor war,
ja, weil hm in dem, weil der erste große Ausbruch, den wir da
äh gesehen äh haben im März im Prinzip. Ähm das waren halt da auch doch konzentrierte Cluster eigentlich eher.
So jetzt hatte sich halt mehr verbreitet und ist jetzt mehr auf der Straße, während des äh vorher auch bei dem Zwischenhoch waren es halt entweder spezielle Betriebe oder spezielle.
Orte, an denen es dann zu Supersprading gekommen ist, Krankenhäuser, Heime, et cetera
aber jetzt durch eben hat es sich halt schön durchmisch,
und da ungefähr davon ausgehen kann, äh dass mindestens jeder zweite äh komplett symptomlos ist äh und das eben weit verbreitet ist. Kann man jetzt
äh ja, es ist viel wahrscheinlicher, dass man tatsächlich jemand einem infizierten begegnet, als das äh
bei der ersten Welle der Fall war, das heißt, gibt jetzt keinen tatsächlich keinen Grund, weniger vorsichtig zu sein und ähm ja.
So, die Zahlen sind jetzt auf einem Niveau, wie sie zuletzt Mitte April. Ähm, ja, Mitte, Ende April.
Hatten wir so viele neue infizierte wie aktuell.
Ja, Winterblues und jetzt ist die Frage, wie lange halten wir das sozusagen mental durch, ne? Weil bisher war das so ein bisschen zehner zusammenbeißen und danach äh war Urlaubszeit.
Die jetzt da noch teilweise anhält, je nach Bundesland.
Das hilft auf jeden Fall dann auch erstmal weiter, aber ich schätze mal so im September und Oktober, wenn dann die Sonne äh weg ist, es wird kühler und alle Fragen stellen sich halt nochmal auf die selbe Art und Weise, plus nochmal verbreitetes Infektionsgeschehen vielleicht
dann ähm sieht das natürlich schon wieder ganz anders aus. Und dann frage ich mich halt, haben wir die richtigen Mittel, u.
Jetzt hier auch in irgendeiner Form einen Modus Operandi zu finden, der dann eben nicht zu so einem Totalausbruch und so einem Pflegefeuer äh der der Infektionen führt.
Die Firma so ein Beispiel ähm nennen, wo ja auch hier gerade drüber diskutiert wird und das ist ja auch dann auch immer gleich ein ein bundesweites Politikum.
Nämlich äh der Fußball, ne. Und.
Ich bin ja äh auch Mitglied in so einem Fußball äh Verein. Den ersten FC Union in Berlin, der so ein bisschen dadurch,
auffällt, dass er äh besonders vehement für neue Methoden, wie man denn mit dieser Situation äh umgehen könnte wirbt,
Äh das hat auch einen konkreten Hintergrund, ähm die ganze Bundesligabetrieb hat man ja gesehen, war ja bisher so Geisterspiele und so Fußball ohne Fans ist halt irgendwie, na ja, ist halt irgendwie nichts, ne? Und äh,
abgesehen davon, dass das jetzt ähm für viele Leute so ein, so ein, so ein, so ein beliebtes Hobby ist, dem äh zuzuschauen.
Gerade auch im äh Fernsehen, ist es natürlich auch eine Branche, die enorm viel Umsatz macht. Also da hängen auch viele Arbeitsplätze dran, et cetera.
Dementsprechend haben natürlich die äh Fußballvereine auch ein großes Interesse da dran, auch wieder Zuschaueranstadion zu bekommen.
Und im Falle von äh Union ist es haut vor allem auch ein großes Interesse des Vereins, weil.
Deswegen gibt's diesen Verein, ja? Das ist sozusagen der der Sinn und Zweck dieses Fußballvereins ist eben genau diese Situation herzustellen.
Und jetzt haben sich natürlich viele so ein bisschen arrangiert und jetzt wird halt so ein bisschen zögerlich darüber diskutiert, so na ja
Und was ist, wenn man dann so jeden fünften Sitzplatz äh mal besetzen würde? Und dann haben wir jetzt ein bisschen mal schon wieder so ein paar tausend mit Klatschpappen, die da irgendwie im Stadion sitzen. Und äh geben sich in dieser Debatte ein bisschen zufrieden und das ist natürlich für Union
überhaupt keine Alternative, weil äh das Stadion dort überhaupt gar keine Sitzplätze hat, also zumindest nicht in den nicht nennenswerten Maße, ja. Also,
wenn du da irgendwie jeden vierten Sitzplatz, äh, Billigskrise, keine tausend Leute ins Stadion oder lohnt sich das irgendwie noch nicht mal das Stadion und da vorne zu öffnen, weil sonst nur noch miese damit machst.
Also, haben sie gesagt, na ja, wenn das jetzt hier mit dem Fußball spielen, so gut funktioniert hat, dann äh können wir das doch auch mit den Zuschauern machen.
Wie wäre es denn, wenn wir einfach mal alle testen lassen vor dem Spiel? Maximal achtundvierzig Stunden vorher.
Und äh dann kommen halt nur die rein, die einen negatives Testergebnis haben. Und äh dann könnte man doch.
Ohne Maske wieder singen und tanzen und springen und schreien und äh seinen Spaß haben und danach wieder nach Hause geht.
Das war so grob äh erstmal die Idee, die so einen Raum geworfen wird und wie du dir vorstellen kannst äh waren sie alle ganz schnell äh äh da sehr zurückhaltend und so, ja, nee und ihr habt's ja nicht mal alle und unverantwortlich und.
Wer soll das bezahlen und,
und so weiter, ne? Also äh sie stand dann erstmal in dieser Debatte, zumindest in der öffentlichen ähm durch die Presse wieder gegebenen Debatte erstmal ziemlich alleine da, halten aber jetzt äh nach wie vor an dieser Idee fest und haben jetzt auch ein Testspiel beantragt.
Äh quasi nach diesem Prinzip funktionieren soll.
Tatsächlich.
Ist es ähm sagen der, der grundsätzliche Ansatz ist auch einer, äh der von Experten favorisiert äh wird. Also ich habe gerade gestern irgendwie ein Interview mit eine,
amerikanischen Forscher gehört, äh der wo meinte, na ja.
Eine Variante, das in Griff zu kriegen ist, wenn äh halt jeder.
Ähm täglich oder alle zwei Tage äh äh getestet wird. Also die gesamte Bevölkerung äh so äh wird alle zwei Tage durchgetestet.
Ist natürlich mit PCR-Test nicht zu mach.
Ist mit PT und PCR-Tests nicht zu machen, ist unrealistisch, da bräucht's halt
andere Arten von Tests, die man eben zu Hause ja so wie wie Schwangerschaftstests und die müssten natürlich in enormen Mengen verfügbar sein so
aber äh
wäre zum Beispiel eine Alternative, um die Zeit zu überbrücken, äh bis einen Impfstoff.
Verfügbar ist. Und ähm ja.
Also so könnte man's faktisch auch in den Griff kriegen und das müsste sogar
äh ganz gut funktionieren, weil selbst wenn es dann ähm sagen auf einer Großveranstaltung jetzt beim Fußball oder so, dann,
doch irgendjemand durch die Lappen kommt oder es äh zu dem Ausfrucht kommt, spätestens sagen nach zwei Tagen, wenn alle wieder durchgetestet werden, äh kann man halt äh.
Ja, zuverlässig äh letztlich sogar nicht nicht nur äh den Ausbruch verhindern, sondern mit so einem alle zwei Tage die Bevölkerung durchtesten,
kann man eigentlich äh auch die Epidemie faktisch zum Stillstand bringen, weil du natürlich,
dann ganz schnell alle infizierten äh äh sagen oder fast alle infizierten rausholst und damit das R auch ganz weit nach un.
Äh äh drückst. So, also von daher,
dieser Ansatz eigentlich äh ja, ist einer der funktionieren kann, wenn äh man es hinbekommt mit dem Testen.
Genau, aber derzeit passiert ja alles noch, ob PCR-Test, also das ist halt auch in diesem Konzept so äh vorgesehen.
Und die Idee ist halt äh mit solchen mobilen Teststationen zu arbeiten. Also es gibt mittlerweile Unternehmen, die bieten halt so Container äh quasi an.
Pipi kannst du sicher, ich glaube nicht, dass sie die Tests da durchführen, aber die bieten sozusagen das sozusagen als Probenentnahmestationen an. Das heißt.
Die Idee ist, wenn du halt jetzt in der Interesse hast, an so einem Spiel als Zuschauer teilzunehmen
lockst du dich da erstmal ein, hinterlässt erstmal alle Informationen, die man so später mal gebrauchen könnte, um das dem Gesundheitsamt zu melden, et cetera, also die du vorhalten musst, im Falle einer Inflation, beziehungsweise Daten, die eben einfach ohnehin angegeben werden müssen,
erstmal einen Test durchführen zu dürfen, ne? Und dann äh wird halt gelost,
also im Falle von Union, äh wäre das so äh erforderlich, weil wenn da dreitausend Plätze äh frei sind, kannst du mal davon ausgehen, dass die äh zehnfach überzeichnet sind.
Und wenn man dann halt den Zuschlag bekommt, erhält man dann äh eine, ja, so eine Art äh Gutschein oder Buchung für so ein Test.
Und kriegt dann halt gesagt, so, na okay, hier so und so viel Uhr, kriegst du so einen zehn Minuten Slot, in dem musst du halt dort auftauchen. Wir haben.
Was weiß ich, fünf oder zehn verschiedene mobile Proben äh einsammelstationen, quer über die Stadt verteilt. Da musst du dann halt irgendwie hinlatschen, genau in diesem zehn Minuten Slot da sein und dann darfst du da deine Probe äh äh abgeben.
Sprich, man macht das glaube ich selber und jemand macht das mit einem, das weiß ich jetzt nicht so ganz genau.
Und dann gibt's halt deine Probe ab, aber du hast so quasi gleich so einen Barcode dabei, ne, wo drin steht hier, ich bin vorangemeldet für Test.
Einmal kurz Piepscan, aha, okay, alles klar, grünes Licht, das ist jetzt hier ins Probezack bumm rein, Röhrchen verschließen, ab in die Kiste und dann geht es halt sofort zum Test. Und dann kriegst du über eine App.
Äh dieses Anbieters kriegst du dann halt eine entsprechende äh negativ oder positiv Bestätigung. Also, wenn positiv dann natürlich kein Fußball,
Gesundheitsamt, aber die meisten Leute werden natürlich dann irgendwie negativ sein. Und damit kannst du dann halt einen Tag später am Stadion auflaufen und dann haben sie sich natürlich noch so.
Was weiß ich, so ein Ampelzonensystem, mit grüne Zone, äh.
Rote Zone, gelbe Zone und so weiter, als je nachdem, da musst du noch mit Mundschutz rumlaufen und Abstand halten und all diese ganzen Geschichten, bis er halt im Stadion bist und wer halt im Stadion ist, ist halt getestet, ist negativ ähm und darf sich dann eben dort ganz normal
verhalten und dann gibt's irgendwie Fußball und viel Schreierei und dann äh ist man halt irgendwann fettig und geht wieder nach Hause. Hat natürlich ein paar interessante Nebeneffekte.
War jetzt ganz abgesehen von den Kosten, ja. Also wenn, wenn äh wenn der Verein sagt, er kann das tragen, dann kann er das tragen. So, ne? Also.
Für dreitausend jetzt oder.
Ja für.
Na ja gut, ich meine, du würdest ja irgendeinen Eintrittspreis ohnehin bezahlen, ob der jetzt sehr viel höher wäre als normal und du da in gewisser Hinsicht einen Anteil hast
kann ich nicht sagen, das steht in diesem Konzept jetzt auch noch nicht drin, ist aber eigentlich auch erstmal egal, kannst einfach nur ausgehen, dass welcher Preis auch immer da aufgerufen wird, Leute würden dann halt,
äh sich finden lassen. Äh es ist übrigens auch so,
dass wenn du dann daran teilnimmst, dass du eben automatisch auch zustimmst quasi an einer wissenschaftlichen Untersuchung teilzunehmen. Also das Ganze ist dann eben auch automatisch ein Forschungsprojekt.
Weil äh gerade wenn das eben so ein regelmäßiger Zyklus ist, wenn ihr jetzt mal davon ausgehst, wäre jetzt eine normale Bundesligasaison und du würdest das halt dann immer mit zwanzigtausend Leuten machen, von denen halt,
Was weiß ich, die Hälfte äh Dauerkartenbesitzer sind, die also alle zwei Wochen.
Immer wieder an denselben Ort kommen und immer wieder regelmäßig getestet werden, dann siehst du dann natürlich, kannst du natürlich daran eine ganze Menge ablesen.
Alter, et cetera, Wohnort, Pipapo, also das ist sozusagen perfektes Studienmaterial, um dort auch nochmal das Wesen des Virus zu erkunden, wenn es denn dann auftritt.
Ja und äh das ist sozusagen die Idee, die jetzt äh diskutiert wird. Dieses Testspiel ist jetzt beantragt, äh da es sich um ein Testspiel handelt und äh unterliegt es eben nicht diesen DFL-Richtlinien.
Äh also deutsche Fußballliga ist ja quasi der Zusammenschluss aller Vereine in der ersten und zweiten Bundesliga, Fußballbundesliga
die ähm sich quasi selber dann eben äh Regeln äh geben, wie sie in diese Saison
diese ganzen äh Spielmodus eben durchziehen und in diesem Fall eben auch diese Chorona-Riegeln rausgeben, die dann eben für alle gelten. Und das war ja eben diese Kreistagsspielsituation der letz,
Monate, die sie jetzt erstmal beibehalten und den nächsten Schritt so weit zu gehen, dass sie sagen, ja, okay, wir testen einfach mal alle
ja, da das äh trauen die sich natürlich jetzt noch nicht. In diesem Testspielfalle ist zumindest auf dem Papier ausschließlich das lokale Gesundheitsamt zuständig.
Und da ja Veranstaltungen bis fünftausend Leute ab äh ich glaube ab.
September auch erlaubt sind, ne? Oder ab Ende August oder so erlaubt sind in Berlin oder jetzt schon erlaubt sind, weiß ich nicht ganz genau. Wenn du denn einen brauchbares Hygienekonzept vorliegst.
Ja, ist es also im Bereich rechtlich möglichen, dass das äh zugelassen werden könnte. Das wird sich dann eben jetzt in den nächsten Wochen, denke ich mal, ähm, abzeichnen, ob's denn nun dazu kommt oder nicht. Ja, dann wäre das dann zumindest mal durchexiziert worden.
Also ich halte das grundsätzlich für eine gute Idee,
das so zu machen. Ich und ich hätte wahrscheinlich auch jetzt nicht so viele Bedenken.
Also oder ja, wenn, also wenn's bei dreitausend Leuten, die alle getestet äh, äh, sind, äh, äh, vorher ähm viel sicherer, geht's wahrscheinlich nicht. Also, es ist äh, dann wahrscheinlich eher, ja,
Ähm also ich halte das für sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass es da dann zum wirklich zu einem super Spredding äh kommt. Äh
unter den Bedingungen oder überhaupt zu Infektionen kommt. Also,
wenn man, ich sage mal, wenn man Schulen aufmachen kann, äh ja, dann äh ähm ja.
Komplett durchgetestete Fußballstadien, die draußen stattfinden. Das ist ja auch nochmal so ein Aspekt, ne? Es ist draußen.
Gut, die werden jetzt dann auch nicht unbedingt alle sofort äh zusammenglucken. Klar, es wird halt irgendwelche Grüppchen äh äh geben, die dann irgendwie gemeinsam rumsingen, aber an sich, denke ich mal, hm
hat sich ja auch so ein gewisses, so ein gewisser Umgang auch schon äh eingependelt, der dann vielleicht nicht bei allen, aber zumindest bei manchen
noch mit reinkommt. Das heißt, die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass es dann wirklich sehr breit äh streut, halte ich dann doch
für diesen relativ kurzen Zeitraum, wo man da zusammenkommt, doch äh für sehr überschaubar.
Aber vielleicht, wir hatten eigentlich mit den Zahlen begonnen und waren jetzt noch nicht ganz durch, äh, äh, bei dem Thema, äh, weil, äh, gut, wir haben.
Mich jetzt den den Anstieg äh.
Aber wir haben auch, es gibt auch so ein paar Lichtblicke äh in den letzten Tagen ähm aus den Zahlen und zwar.
War es so, dass noch vor einer Woche waren,
äh die Zahlen in allen Bundesländern äh am Steigen. So, das heißt, es gab, ja.
In äh äh nur in hundert Landkreisen äh gegen die Zahlen nicht hoch, in dreihundert Landkreisen hatten wir äh äh von vierhundert irgendwas hatten wir halt steigende äh Zahlen und in allen
Bundesländern. Mittlerweile ist es aber wieder so, also gestern war es so, dass äh wir kna
und dass wir in, glaube ich, in sieben oder acht äh Bundesländern wieder fallende Zahlen hatten, äh das setzt sich fort, also aktuell äh ist es so, dass in sieben Bundesländern
die äh Zahlen rückläufig sind wieder. So
Obwohl äh wir halt auf Bundesebene äh nach wie vor noch einen Anstieg haben. Äh.
Gibt es eben auch Anzeichen äh jetzt gerade dafür, dass es zurückgeht und schaut man auch auf die Berliner Zahlen äh so Berlin
ist gefühlt immer so ein bisschen ein Vorreiter, das heißt ähm so äh Berlin, wenn die wenn die Zahlen anfangen, hochzugehen
äh in Berlin, dann gehen sie hinten später auch im Bund hoch und wenn sie in Berlin fallen, dann fallen sie mit
bisschen Verspätung anschließend auch im Bund. Und in Berlin haben wir tatsächlich jetzt die eher erfreuliche äh Situation
dass äh ja R, das sieben Tage R jetzt um die eins, beziehungsweise je nach Interpulationsmethode sogar äh bei null Komma neun ist und ähm.
Ja, dass die Zahlen, dass das in Berlin jetzt äh zwar sehr langsam, aber.
Aktuell rückläufig sind, beziehungsweise es auf jeden Fall, äh, ja, sie nicht weiter ansteigen. So,
und das, äh, obwohl die Schulen ähm geöffnet haben und äh so weiter, also insofern, äh, ja, ähm, gewisse Lichtblicke äh sind.
Im Moment da, was jetzt nicht heißt, äh dass man jetzt schon Entwarnung äh geben kann, aber.
So mein Gefühl äh nachdem ich da jetzt seit Monaten auf die Zahlen gucke, ist.
Das ist eine ganz gute Wahrscheinlichkeit gibt, dass.
Die Zahlen jetzt in der nächsten Woche dann auch im Bund, äh wir äh wieder sinkende Zahlen sehen werden.
Was ja dann sozusagen schon das Ende der dritten Welle wäre, ne? Wenn man jetzt mal auf.
Ja
Guckt, ne? Alle reden von der zweiten Welle, die ist eigentlich schon durch. Das ist jetzt gerade die dritte und äh keiner weißt du recht noch, wie hoch sie sein wird, aber könnte halt auch wieder fallen.
Also ja, die Berliner Zahlen, wenn man, wenn man draufguckt, geben da Anlass zur Hoffnung, wobei man auch immer,
sagen muss, ja, in die Diskussion, um die Qualität der Zahlen und die ganzen Faktoren, die die Verzerren und so und äh und überall eventuell Überlastung äh der.
Gesundheitsämter und Ausweitung der Tests und so können das natürlich alles beeinflussen, aber äh unterm Strich äh sage ich mal ähm.
Äh sieht es nicht katastrophal aus, sondern äh.
Auch wenn man die Zahlen der Toten betrachtet, in Berlin, da hatten wir sogar jetzt, ja, über eine Woche, äh, gab es in Berlin keinen einzigen Todesfall.
Jetzt gab's die letzten beiden Tage wieder zwei. So, also von daher und sagen.
Ist es noch einigermaßen äh im Griff, dass die die Situation bisher und nur ähm sagt, er muss halt unter eins wieder, weil.
Sonst sind wir irgendwann an einem Punkt, wo es eben definitiv aussah Kontrolle ist, aber den haben wir noch nicht erreicht und äh.
Acht in Berlin. Ja, besteht Hoffnung, dass die Zahlen auch wieder runtergehen.
Beziehungsweise unseren hoffentlich auch auch im Bund und in vielen anderen Ländern eben auch, wie gesagt, von
in allen Ländern, vor einer Woche, in allen Ländern, Anstiege, jetzt in fast die Hälfte der Bundesländer.
Gehen die Zahlen zurück. Also, das heißt, kann sein, dass du auch viel einfach mit der Reisetätigkeit die Reiserückkehrer, äh, die wir, die wir hatten.
Testausweitung und so, äh, dass das zum großen Teil, äh, diese dritte Welle jetzt befeuert hat.
Ja, ich schaue mir gerade die Zahlen auch nochmal an, gerade in Punkto auf äh Todesfälle, also fällt mir auf, dass einfach Nordrhein-Westfalen einfach überproportional betroffen ist.
Ja, also NRW war auch in den letzten Wochen äh tatsächlich äh.
Ähm so das Bundesland, äh wo am meisten los war, in den Top dreißig.
Waren äh teilweise die Hälfte der Landkreise äh waren aus NRW. So fünfzehn von dreißig ähm,
dann waren da noch immer zwei, drei Berliner Bezirke mit drin, in den top dreißig und dann bisschen Bayern, bisschen Hessen, äh, ja, bisschen Schleswig-Holstein, aber äh.
Tja, gibt's kein Karneval, ne?
Tja, ja, die Diskussion lief ja jetzt, äh, läuft jetzt auch wieder, so von wegen, ja. Karneval könnte man ja nicht verbieten. Das war ja irgendwie unmöglich.
Aber Fußball, na toll. Da bin ich ja sehr für äh Geisterkarneval.
Ja, Karnevalsumzüge ohne ah.
Auf Zoom. Wir alle. Das muss jetzt alles im Internet gemacht werden, Internetkarneval. Mhm.
Internet, Karneval her oder so.
Tja, na okay, äh für irgendjemanden, den Spaß nehmen, ähm wir wollen ja alle äh letzten Endes wieder das äh tun, was wir am liebsten machen, aber ich habe auch so ein bisschen den Eindruck, so ein paar Sachen werden langfristig auch irgendwie auf der Strecke bleiben müssen.
Bis äh bis wir hier wirklich eine eine biologische Antwort gefunden haben, die nachhaltig ist.
Naja, da ist ja, also sieht es so aus, als wenn ja.
Dir einen Impfstoff, also wenn eigentlich Normalität komplette Normalität wir erst hinkriegen, wenn ein Großteil der Bevölkerung durchgeimpft ist,
da äh tut sich halt auch ähm,
extrem viel äh an der Impfstofffront. Also weltweit mich gehört befinden, sich um die sechzig verschiedene Impfstoffe gerade.
In der klinischen Erprobung und ähm ich glaube ja, um die dreihundert Impfstoffe
äh äh sind Tests beantragt, das heißt es ist nicht so, dass jetzt irgendwie nur hier eins, zwei, drei äh oder zehn äh
ähm Impfstoffe entwickelt werden, äh sondern ja hunderte. Es gibt hunderte von Impfstoffprojekten, äh die gerade laufen und,
ähm, glaube noch, noch nie in der Geschichte der Menschheit, ist äh so viel Energie
Geld auf äh die Entwicklung eines bestimmten Impfstoffs geworfen äh worden. Gut, wir wissen immer noch nicht hundert Prozentig
äh wie gut und wie lange äh die Impfstoffe schützen werden, aber ähm.
Da besteht äh doch derzeit Hoffnung, dass das funktionieren wird, dass das klappen wird. Und dass wir wahrscheinlich spätestens ähm.
In der ja ersten Jahreshälfte nächsten Jahres, Impfstoffe, erste Impfstoffe haben werden.
Die auch äh in der Breite verabreicht werden können. Es gab ja da auch die kontroverse, um diese äh russische Impfstoffmeldung von wegen, ja, die Russen haben jetzt einen Impfstoff
ja letztlich sagt es sind gerade sechzig Impfstoffe, die gerade erpro.
Werden. Äh und das heißt, es g.
Nicht nur den russischen Impfstoff, sondern es gibt auch noch, ja, sechzig andere Impfstoffe, die genauso weit sind. Das Problem ist halt, äh, mit den Impfstoffen, ähm.
Wenn man jetzt wirklich einen signifikanten Anteil, weiß nicht, fünfzig, sechzig, achtzig Prozent der Bevölkerung durch impfen will
wenn man einen Impfstoff haben, der wirklich extrem sicher und verträglich ist, weil äh bei, ja.
Letztlich weltweit. Wann will man, ja, sagen wir mal, vier, fünf Milliarden Menschen äh impfen.
Und selbst wenn du nur irgendwie einen Impfstoff hast, der nur eine.
Promille an im äh äh schwere Impfschäden verursacht, äh so dann äh reden wir da, ja, von zig Millionen äh äh.
Ten, die durch die Impfung äh Schäden äh erreichen. Insofern ist das, das ist halt das Kernproblem, dass man halt äh extrem sichere Impfstoffe haben will,
interessant ist auch in dem Zusammenhang äh natürliche Herdenimmunität,
äh werden wir so schnell nicht erreichen. Also wer auch immer da am Anfang drauf gesetzt hat, äh das sieht nicht so aus, als wenn's.
Funktioniert und selbst in, es gibt ja so ein paar Gegenden, wo es so viele Infektionen gegeben hat
dass da mittlerweile teilweise in Menschen gegen den vierzig Prozent äh in New York sollen sogar sonst zwanzig Prozent der Bevölkerung sein
die äh.
Bereits eine Infektion äh durchgemacht haben, aber da hat man gesehen, dass selbst jetzt zwanzig Prozent äh nicht ausreichend,
äh sind. Und die andere Sache äh ist halt, was wir auch wissen von anderen.
Und nochmal enddemischen äh Viren und müssen davon ausgehen, dass Chorona auch indem ich äh wird, also das äh wir es nicht komplett ausgerottet kriegen, sondern
ist immer irgendwo ähm zu Infektionen kommen wird, wie bei anderen,
Erkrankungen auch wie bei Grippe äh oder äh ja sich Masern, rötteln, ähm.
Und solche Dinge, äh die haben ja auch teilweise nie äh komplett ausgerottet gekriegt, aber ähm da nur Dank,
äh dank Impfstoffen äh so äh stellen diese Erkrankungen äh kein Problem da und nicht dank Herden immunität, also bevor es äh,
nicht die Impfstoffe äh gab äh war auch eigentlich Herdenimmunität äh nicht,
hinreichend, ja? Sondern du hast es werden natürlich immer neue äh ähm Menschen geboren, ohne diese Immunität und allein äh sagen, die Zahl der äh jenigen, die dann dazu kommen
reicht halt dann für einen größeren Ausbruch alle paar Jahre.
Aus, so. Das heißt, äh wir brauchen einen Impfstoff, so alles andere äh ja.
Wenn man sich so die Infektions äh äh Kurve anschaut in den USA, also wenn die so weitermachen, dann ähm.
Sind die also gut unterwegs. So, also die haben jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, knapp sechs Millionen infizierte, bestätigte, ja? Äh, wenn man da jetzt mal auch nur so eine ganz zurückhaltende ähm.
Dunkelziffer mal ran nimm, sagen wir mal so Faktor drei oder sowas, was ja sicherlich äh greifbar äh wäre, dann hast du's schon so mit sechs Prozent der Bevölkerung zu tun.
So und das haben sie jetzt irgendwie in äh ja in fünf Monaten geschafft.
Mhm. Ja, aber, wie gesagt, ähm.
Das ist so, das ist nicht nicht wirklich einen einen Weg plus, du hast dann die ganzen Geschädigten, also der Unterschied ist ja auch
äh bin ich geimpft werde. So, dann habe ich die Immunitä.
Ohne, dass meine Lunge und mein Herz und meine Nieren möglicherweise äh äh in Mitleidenschaft gezogen äh worden sind. Das heißt ähm den, den echten Virus äh äh zu nehmen,
ähm um immun zu werden, ist eine schlechte.
Bisschen unklug, ne? Ja.
Ist äh einfach mal teuer erkauft, äh äh diese Immunit.
Ja, Zweifelsohne. Zweifelsohne.
Ja, und das will man einfach auch nicht im großen Maßstab,
äh äh machen, sondern wenn dann will ich meine sechzig, siebzig, achtzig Prozent halt durch Impfung erreichen und ja äh.
Schauen wir doch mal, was sich so in Digitalien äh getan hat. Wir haben hier auch ganz traditionell äh immer viel über mögliche, digitale Lösungen und also so moderne Technik und sowas
Computer, Telefon und so, gesprochen und natürlich vor allem über die Chorona Warnapp.
Da lohnt sich sicherlich jetzt auch mal einen Blick da drauf, weil die ja jetzt seit zwei Monaten im Feld ist.
Und Linos schon im Rahmen von der Lochbuchnetzpolitik diese Woche äh bisschen drüber gesprochen hat, paar Zahlen äh gerollt. Vielleicht können wir da ja auch nochmal äh kurz ähm ein kleines Meinungsbild zusammen
bestellen. Also schauen wir mal auf die Zahlen.
Es werden vor allem wenige veröffentlicht. Also das ist so meine, meine Kernkritik eigentlich derzeit an der Art und Weise, wie dieses Projekt gehandhabt wird. Ähm alles, was bisher vom RKI veröffentlicht wird, sind.
Die Downloads der App.
So. Und das äh ist natürlich insofern schon mal ein bisschen schwach, als das natürlich downloads, wenig darüber aussagen, wie viele Leute betreiben diese App.
Und da habe ich ehrlich gesagt.
Wenig bis gar kein Verständnis für, dass dass dass diese Zahl nicht genannt wird. Ich kann ja natürlich verstehen, dass solche Download-Zahlen dann in irgendeiner Form, die etwas positivere Botschaft sind, weil.
Der Download hat stattgefunden, das ist, sagen wir mal, die höchstmögliche Zahl, die man erreichen kann. Äh, die liegt jetzt, äh, Stand heute bei siebzehn Komma zwei.
Millionen.
Wenn man sich das so äh über die Zeit halt anschaut, war die Download-Aktivität so vor allem in den ersten zwei, drei äh Wochen sehr hoch,
und so nach einem Monat,
war eigentlich die Kurve schon extrem flach und seitdem ist auch nicht mehr so sehr viel dazu gekommen. Kann man sich natürlich jetzt fragen, woran liegt das.
Ich glaube, es hat vor allem viel damit zu tun, dass relativ wenig dann dran gearbeitet wurde, die Nützlichkeit dieser App noch weiter in den Vordergrund zu stellen. Klar, man hat hier und dabei Fußball irgendwie ein paar Wanderolen geschaltet und irgendwelche.
Leute, äh, äh, ja, haben da so Werbeeinblendungen gemacht, aber das jetzt wirklich mal ähm.
Aktiv dran gearbeitet wurde, dieses Vertrauen in in dieses Modell weiter zu erhöhen. Das habe ich halt so nicht gesehen. Ich habe so den Eindruck, man hat sich erstmal relativ here Ziele am Anfang äh gesetzt und ähm dann war man froh, als es irgendwie alles veröffentlicht war und.
War das Thema so Next so, ja, jetzt, jetzt, jetzt machen wir was anderes. Da fehlt es auch so ein bisschen an dem richtigen Produktmanagement, meiner Meinung nach.
Es gibt jetzt hier diese äh Webseite von dem Michael Böhme, der sich äh versucht äh daran anhand der öffentlich einsehbaren Datenströme, die diese App ja erzeugt, ein paar Einschätzungen zu machen.
Wie viel äh denn diese App tatsächlich benutzt wird.
Dazu gibt's noch eine weitere öffentliche Quelle, nämlich wie viele Teletanz ausgegeben worden sind.
Das sind äh bisher tausendsechshundertneunundsiebzig ist die letzte Zahl, also Teletan ist quasi die ähm.
Titan, mit der man eben selber seine Schlüssel freigibt. Also, wenn Leute infiziert sind, einen positiven Test bekommen haben und dann sagen, okay, mit der App, mit der ich jetzt die letzten zwei Wochen rumgerannt bin.
Gebe ich jetzt meinen Schlüssel frei und warne damit eben potenziell auch andere
Diese Zahl liegt halt bei tausend äh sechshundertneunundsiebzig. Das ist wohlgemerkt, nur diese Teletan. Eigentlich ist es ja vorgesehen, dass man
diesen ganzen Vorgang automatisiert macht, das heißt in dem Moment, wo ich einen Test bekomme, kriege ich so ein Zettelchen, da steht ein QR-Code drauf, den scanne ich mit meiner App
und äh später wird dann eben, wenn das Ergebnis da ist, äh meiner App Bescheid gesagt und dann kann ich das so direkt machen, dann brauche ich diese Teletaten nicht.
Da gab's jetzt einige Berichte, dass ähm erstmal viele Labore noch gar nicht angeschlossen sind, also viele Labore, diesen ganzen Prozess nicht umgesetzt haben,
Aus welchen Gründen auch immer, also da ist es ein bisschen schwierig mit dem Fingerpointing, also da äh ist sicherlich an vielen Stellen ähm da auch noch weitere Fehler gemacht worden, das kann ich so im einzelnen nicht genau,
äh zuordnen, Tatsache ist, dass äh teilweise eben bei den Laboren dieser Prozess nicht vollständig umgesetzt wurde,
woran es auch immer äh gelegen haben mag. Gut, da muss man ein bisschen ans Datenbankmodell ran, da muss man irgendwie Softwarekomponenten abstimmen und das ist dann vielleicht auch nicht nur, um unbedingt eine einzige, aber daran äh haperts,
der Spahn hat gesagt, sie hätten halt ungefähr so zwei Drittel der Labor schon äh ab ähm angeschlossen.
Ganz genau, ob das stimmt. Ich habe auch Berichte gehört von Leuten, die gesagt haben.
Ja, ich hatte sowas. Ich hatte äh diesen QR-Code, ich habe den auch gescannt. Äh mein Arzt hat mich hier nächsten Tag angerufen und hat gesagt, hier, Testergebnis, aber äh nach zwei Wochen war halt in der App selber auch immer noch nichts zu sehen. Also, da gibt's auf jeden Fall noch Probleme
Ähm, wo ich gerade nicht so richtig sagen kann, ähm,
was es ist. Die interessante Auswertung jetzt hier auf dieser äh Seite, was eigentlich von welcher Seite, ich spreche Pavel.
Ja.
Ich schicke dir mal ganz kurz hier nochmal den äh Link so ganz unter uns.
Die Seite schlüsselt ja auch auf, wie viele gemeldete neue Infektionen ähm.
Wie die im Verhältnis stehen zu dieser Aktivität dieser App.
Also wie viel Schlüssel werden letzten Endes über dieses Corona-Bahn-App über diesen Server veröffentlicht? Wie viele davon sind echte Schlüssel, weil da sind ja immer noch diese Fake-Schlüssel äh mit drin. Und wie verhält sich das eben äh zu den
tatsächlich gemeldeten Neuinfektionen. Und dann wird das Ganze so im Prozent äh ausgegeben. Und
diese Zahl stagniert, also die ist äh ziemlich rüttelig, das ist mal so mal so, also da waren so Höchstwerte, einzelne Spikes, mal fünfzehn Prozent mal zehn Prozent mal elf Prozent
sieben, acht Prozent, aber so im Mittel würde ich sagen, liegt das so ungefähr so bei fünf. Vielleicht sechs.
Prozent. Äh das heißt, das ist quasi der Anteil der Leute, die ein positives Testergebnis bekommen, die auch tatsächlich diese Chorona Bahn-App äh einsetzen und dann eben auch.
Nutzen. Das steht dann quasi äh.
Der Download-Zahl, die ja die einzige Zahl für die Verbreitung ist, die wir haben, ja, die man ja so hochrechnen kann, auf knapp ein Fünftel der Bevölkerung.
Also, äh, gemessen an Bevölkerung, die älter als fünfzehn Jahre ist. Und oder ab fünfzehn, weiß ich mal ganz genau.
Glaube ab fünfzehn.
So, dass man sagen könnte, na okay, also nur ein Viertel derjenigen, die wohl theoretisch äh hätten, das nutzen äh können.
Haben es auch tatsächlich erfolgreich durchgeführt.
Oder Leute, die die Coronawarn-App einsetzen.
Ähm sind vorsichtiger. Und weniger von den äh infizieren sich tatsächlich. Das könnte halt auch eine Erklärung äh sein.
Wobei wir eine Debatte ja vorher immer gehört haben, dass er die Koroner Bannet unter Umständen deshalb so gefährlich ist, weil die Leute ja dann unvorsichtig werden. Weil sie ja denken, sie werden jetzt durch die App geschützt. Ich glaube, das hat sich nicht so sehr bewahrheitet.
Ne
Also jedenfalls, ja, nee, also wenn ich irgendwo rein äh gehe, ist, ich glaube, eher so eine, so eine Maske, äh, die man aufsetzt, macht eher mutiger als,
die Chorona-App, äh die man da äh in der Tasche hat. Also, ja,
wahrscheinlich also die Wahrheit liegt vermutlich irgendwo in der Mitte. Die Wahrheit liegt vermutlich daran, dass äh nicht zwanzig Prozent oder nicht, dass ein ein Gewisseranteil, die die Ap
runtergeladen haben, sie nicht betreiben oder sie nicht wirklich funktioniert bei ihnen oder wie auch immer.
Aber das wahrscheinlich auch Leute, die jetzt die Chorona Warn-App sich runtergeladen haben, eher zu denjenigen, gehören, äh, die sich einen Kopf machen
und die sich auch äh in ihrem, ja, andere Maßnahmen äh zum Schutz ernster nehmen, als vielleicht
äh die ja ähm sage mal achtzig Prozent äh die sie nicht runtergeladen äh äh haben
aus welchem Grund auch immer so, äh, aber man sagen, ja, ich weiß, wer, wer die App, äh, einen einfacher.
Ja, es ist ja nicht kost ja nix und ist vom Aufwand her äh auch nicht besonders aufwendig, das zu tun und wenn jemand nicht mal diesen Schritt
irgendwo hinbekommt oder initiiert, ähm ja, fragt, kann man sich natürlich dann schon fragen, auch äh äh wie sich diese Person ist, äh, anderweitig mit mit Schutz erhal,
Klasse, nicht alle achtzig Prozent so, aber das wäre so fast eher meine These noch, warum wir.
Dort nur die fünf Prozent sehen.
Jetzt muss man sich natürlich auch fragen, ist denn die Corana Wahn-App eigentlich für die Situation auch noch äh das richtige Werkzeug.
Als das alles spezifiziert diskutiert äh und politisch ausgeknobelt und dann letztlich auch entwickelt wurde
gab's ja äh im Wesentlichen diesen Duktus mit der Abstand ist entscheidend. Und jetzt machen wir hier Bluetooth und dann messen wir den Abstand. Und alles, was irgendwie weiter weg ist, als zwei Meter. Das ist dann irgendwie keine Gefahr mehr
So, ne? Das ist ja im Prinzip so ein bisschen die Logik, nach der dieser App äh arbeitet und da steckt natürlich auch so ein bisschen dieser Gedanke dahinter. Ähm.
Abstand ist so ein bisschen äh auch der Versuch, Leute rauszufiltern, dass man eben einfach auch nicht zu viele Benachrichtigt.
Jetzt haben wir natürlich die Situation, dass mittlerweile der Wissenschaftliche Konsens mehr so in diese Richtung geht, so Innenräume sind gefährlich.
Und da ist dann der Abstand ein Faktor, aber eben nicht nur, sondern das hat eher was damit zu tun, ob du da
eine Klimaanlage hast, die selber keinen Filter hat und dann die Luft sozusagen nochmal extra schön im Kreis äh dreht. Da gab's ja auch schon vor Monaten aus China entsprechende Fälle, dass das eben durch äh Klimaanlagen in Restaurants weiter verbreitet wurde
generell trockene Duft also schlechte Belüftung, enge Räume
und in Abhängigkeit davon eben, wie viele Leute sind denn da auch wirklich drin? Und was machen die Leute, ja, im Fitnessstudio bisher jetzt am Hecheln und am Keuchen und mach's irgendwie Action. Und das sind ja alles so Dinge
die so eine App überhaupt nicht einfangen kann. Weder weiß die App, ob ich in einem Raum bin, noch weiß die App, ob ich
ob viele Leute da sind. Klar, sie sind halt irgendwelche äh Schlüssel, aber kann sozusagen daraus keine, keine, keine Schlüsse ziehen. Äh.
Aber ich denke so primär auch gerade so dieses äh drin draußen Ding, das ist ja da überhaupt nicht eingepreist. Und es gibt halt in dem Sinne auch überhaupt gar kein
Schalter, der jetzt sagen könnte, ja, in dieser Umgebung ist jetzt eine höhere Gefahr, als in dieser anderen Umgebung. Und ehrlich gesagt, ich sehe da jetzt auch relativ wenig
Möglichkeiten dem automatisiert beizukommen. Also es könnte ein paar geben, aber.
Das müsste ja dann letzten Endes auch noch so umgesetzt werden. Also, eine Idee zum Beispiel wäre, die Telefone haben ja alle GPS-Empfänger.
Kommen wir natürlich wieder so in gefährliches Gebiet, ne? Oh, GPS und so weiter. Mir geht's jetzt nicht um Location, sondern mir geht's dadrum, wenn das Telefon.
Schaut, ob es GPS Satelliten sieht oder nicht. Ja und es sieht keine. Oder es sieht nur einen oder so.
Dann ist so die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass man sich in einem geschlossenen Raum befindet, sehr viel höher, als wenn man ganz viele sieht.
Das ist definitiv, ja, das ist eine coole Ide.
Ja, so damit nimmt man nicht unbedingt die Location her, sondern es ist eigentlich mehr so ein Abfallprodukt von dem, was das Telefon sowieso eigentlich die ganze Zeit tut, nicht im Kontext dieser App, sondern eben Kontext, der Funktionalität dieses Telefons, das heißt, es kann schon sein
dass man eben
äh eine eine Methode finden könnte, dass man sagt, okay, du bist jetzt wahrscheinlich eher drin, du bist jetzt schon eher draußen und damit natürlich auch so ein neuen Risikofaktor damit reinmachen kannst. Man sagen kann, weiß ich, jetzt bist du drin,
und jetzt zählt aber nicht der Abstand äh Bluetooth Signal, den man so normalerweise heranziehen würde für anderthalb oder zwei Meter. Son,
erweitern wir das einfach mal auf zehn Meter. Sowas.
Das wäre eine Variante und das andere, was sich ja auch.
Irgendwie in einer der letzten Sendung, ich vielleicht sogar in der letzten äh ja, jedenfalls äh die Idee ähm eben auch
sogenannte ja Location bietens einzusetzen, das heißt äh, dass.
Nicht nur Personen jetzt potenziell ansteckend sind, äh sondern sagen Orte, das heißt, dass dann halt, äh, sagen die Kneipe oder das Geschäft oder wie auch immer, äh, selber auch einen Bieken oder Beakons
hat, äh die am System teilnehmen und die dann auch äh eben äh Warnungen,
verschicken können, wenn äh beziehungsweise wo man dann, äh, wenn es
äh wenn ein eine infizierte Person
an einem bestimmten Ort war und man zwar jetzt nicht direkten Bieten von der Person bekommen hat, aber es eben ein geschlossener Raum ist und äh sagen, dass dann entsprechend das weitergeleitet wird. Das wäre, glaube ich,
auch noch einen Ansatz, der insbesondere
auch äh vielleicht eine brauchbare Ersatz für das Führen von äh diesen unsäglichen Listen äh sein äh könnt, die ja ein riesen Problem
auch darstellen, weil
angefangen von den ganzen Adressmissbrauchsfällen äh zu denen es gekommen ist von Leuten, die sich in Listen eingetragen haben bis zu dem umgekehrten Dingen, dass halt viele Leute dann Fantasieadressen dort eintragen und nicht benachricht.
Äh äh sind, das könnte vielleicht auch helfen, aber.
Ja, das erfordert natürlich Schritte und Energie und ja.
Ja, eine Möglichkeit, die ich ähm im Lok-Potentialspolitik angedacht, aber nicht so richtig zu Ende gedacht habe.
Wäre ja, dass man diese Chorona-Warn-App auch quasi so als Kontakt benutzt. Also du hast ja eben deine Idee mit den war ja eher.
Der Ort sagt, ich bin der Ort oder ich bin ein bestimmter Ort. Ja, sodass die App sich das sozusagen merkt und diese Information.
Zum Zeitpunkt der.
Äh Schlüssel veröffentlichung mit weitergibt oder wie hast du dir das vorgestellt? Also, das ist sozusagen jetzt auch nochmal so ein Datenschutz äh äh Problem an der Stelle natürlich. Man könnte natürlich genauso gut auch einfach.
Ein Telefon mit einer Chorona Warnapp einfach mitten im Restaurant äh positionieren. Und selber einsammeln. Das meinst.
Genau, vielmehr wäre das nicht außer, dass man also der einzige Unterschied äh wäre, dass dann sozusagen die Location würde dann äh eine Warnung empfangen,
ja?
Ganz normal, wie auch jeder andere, äh, weil die Location ja selber auch dann den infizierten gesehen hat, der jetzt meldet. So, das heißt, die Location kriegt jetzt die Warnung.
Und das Einzige, äh was sie dann sagen, tun müsste, äh äh wäre, sagen diese Warnung dann äh weiterzuschicken an alle Beakons, äh äh die sie äh.
Gut, aber dann müsste die App eben diese Funktionalität einer Warnung haben. Und das ist ja etwas, was die deutsche App nicht
sie, so eine österreichischen ist es ja vorgesehen, ich weiß aber nicht genau, mit welchem Erfolg das mittlerweile so äh betrieben wurde, ist natürlich auch nochmal so ein bisschen problematisch, insbesondere im Hinblick auf das immer noch nicht
umgesetzte ähm Verteilen der Schlüssel auf europäischer Ebene, ne? Weil da musste ja,
dann auch alle gleich behandeln. Also der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner ist eigentlich das Verteilen von echten Diagnosekies, aber diese Warnungen sind etwas äh was in gewisser Hinsicht noch mit dazugebaut werden könnte oder müsste
Das ist natürlich leistbar, ja? Das wäre sozusagen so ein, so ein, so ein zusätzlicher Faktor, aber dazu müsste im Prinzip diese ganze App nochmal neu äh gemacht werden.
Ja
Ja, also ja, während bisschen neue Features eigentlich, aber.
Eigentlich kein großer Aufwand, jetzt ist eher eher dann sagen der logistische äh Aufwand und sagen, wann bin ich berechtigt eigentlich, äh so ein,
Location äh zu betreiben,
äh zu versenden und so, weil äh da würde man schon wollen, ja, dass das zumindest Gewissen Einschränkungen unterliegt, dass nicht jeder irgendwie mit so einem Location-Tracker äh rum,
läuft.
Ja, man könnte, ja, man könnte halt sagen, Orte könnten sich explizit freischalten lassen für diese Funktionalität,
wäre zum Beispiel so eine Sache, dass man sagt so, ja okay, das ist jetzt hier sozusagen unser Restauranthandy und das äh ist jetzt nur genau dafür äh eingerichtet. Also ich will das jetzt nicht
gleich als die die geile Lösung und genauso müsste man's machen, darstellen, weil muss man im Detail nochmal so ein bisschen drüber nachdenken, weil es hat doch eine ganze Menge Implikationen
ne? Ähnlich die Idee, dass eben diese, dieser Zwang zur äh Aufnahme in einer Kontaktliste gegebenenfalls auch mit der Warnapp gemacht werden könnte
Also, dass man sagt, hier die Corona Warnapp zeigt bestimmten QR-Cold an.
Und ähm der kann dann halt entweder weggescannt werden.
So, dass du sozusagen auch die Chorona-Bahn-App so als Datenersatz, ne, so nach dem Motto, okay, du musst,
seine Daten nicht geben, aber wenn ich äh einmal kurz äh das Fex scannen kann, hast du deine Pflicht erfüllt an diesem Ort,
ja, alternativ, wenn's diese Scannmöglichkeit nicht gibt, dass eben dieser QR-Code äh in irgendeiner Form so als so, was weiß ich, so zwölf Zeichen stringen, so wie eine Kreditkarte, äh, eine Kreditkartennummer, ja, mit Buchstaben,
das weiß ich so, BL acht, neun, Strich, D sechs, vier, fünf, Strich äh ABCD. Ja, und dann schreibst du das auf.
Ja, dann ist das sozusagen deine deine in dem Moment gültige äh äh Signatur und dann kannst du irgendwie diese Informationen äh hinterlassen.
Bist damit sozusagen auch.
Letztlich ja letztlich geht's ja darum, dass du erreichbar bist.
Falle, äh dass dort bis äh zu einem Sprading gekommen ist, äh ja, äh dass du halt benachrichtigt werden kannst. Wobei.
Lang die Variante mit dem ersten aus meiner Sicht weniger Privatsphäre äh Risiken äh enthält als äh ja.
Wenn du dort jetzt einen QR-Code oder wie auch immer, hinterlässt, aber.
Ne, das Ganze ist ja auch nur sozusagen so ein anonymer Code, über den ich notifiziert werden kann und die App würde letzten Endes auch nichts anderes sagen, als hallo hier, du warst irgendwie eine am Ort.
Wo du, wo du dich mal eingetragen hast, eine Kontaktliste, bitte mal Gesundheitsamt anrufen, fertig. So, und mehr geht's ja gar nicht
Also, das sind alles so Sachen. Also, worauf ich eigentlich hinaus will, ist, mir fehlt gerade so ein bisschen die Musik in der, in der, in der Weiterentwicklung, äh, dieses Konzept ist. Äh, es hakt natürlich derzeit noch einen ganz grundsliegenden Sachen. Wir haben immer noch nicht diese europäische
Einheitlichkeit, also gerade jetzt, meiner Erwartung war ja eigentlich, dass das müsste eigentlich zur Reisezeit irgendwie dort dann doch umgesetzt worden sein.
Wird jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder tausend rechtliche behördliche Länder, EU, bla, bla, äh, Gründe gehabt haben, warum das jetzt irgendwie nicht geklappt hat.
Finde ich schade. Hätte ich auch ehrlich gesagt gedacht, dass das ein bisschen schneller gehen könnte. Aber so ist nun mal die Realität. Hat nicht stattgefunden.
Andererseits auch nach diesem Sommer wird es noch europäische Reiseaktivität geben und von daher macht es nach wie vor sind das nachzuliefern.
Ja, definitiv. Also, das ist ja die andere Sache, dass halt jetzt, äh, nur, weil die Urlaubszeit zu Ende ist, ja äh das nicht ein Ende der Reiseaktivitäten bedeutet, äh wobei ähm.
Ja, das ist dann andere Arten von Reisen äh sind.
Es gibt immer noch Pendler und es gibt immer noch Geschäftsleute, die äh aus welchen Gründen auch immer durch die Gegend fahren müssen. Es gibt immer noch Lastwagenfahrer, es gibt immer noch äh andere, die unterwegs sind, also.
Nebensaisonurlauber.
Das kommt auch alles noch. Ja, haben wir noch was.
Wir wollten ja heute erstmal so einen kleinen äh machen und überhaupt erstmal so alles äh einsammeln, was uns noch so äh im Kopf ist und dann schauen wir mal, wie wir äh hier auch wieder so eine gewisse
Regelmäßigkeit vielleicht reinkommen können, um um das Geschehen dann auch etwas genauer zu begleiten.
An der Stelle vielleicht auch an unsere Hörerinnen und hörernormale Hinweise, also wenn ihr sozusagen jetzt so Tipps habt und uns noch auf bestimmte Sachen hinweisen möchtet, macht das bitte gerne, äh, gerne auch über Twitter, über ME Unterstrich UKW
oder schreibt mich oder Pavel äh direkt an, wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall sind wir dafür alles ähm offen.
Ja, äh, ich würde sagen, dass wir das dann vielleicht auch in der nächsten äh Sendung äh machen, weil es sich da ja auch eine ganze Menge Feedback jetzt angesammelt hat, auf das wir heute nicht eingegangen sind, aber mal sagen, wir haben's.
Zur Kenntnis äh genommen und äh wir haben da, äh, denke ich, äh, ja, bei der nächsten äh Sendung auch nochmal auf Hinweise, Fragen, Kritik äh zu den Zahlen, äh.
Und so weiter. Da vielleicht mal äh dann ein bisschen näher drauf drauf eingehen.
Genau. Und allein unsere Präsenz wird jetzt schon dazu führen, dass die Zahlen wieder sinken, ne? Weil man hat gemerkt, kaum senden wir nicht gegen die Zahlen hoch.
Haben wir ja eher stimmt. Das ist ja kaum.
Haben wir nur Tim, was haben wir getan? Ja, kaum haben wir irgendwie machen wir Pause hier äh schon.
Einfach eine Machtdemonstration, ja, ist einfach.
Ja, ja, ja.
Es hängt, es hängt dann auch von den Downloadzahlen ab, vom Podcast, ne? Also, wenn die dann nicht hochgehen, dann gehen auch die anderen Zahlen nicht runter. Ganz.
Ja
Ich meine zum, wer ich zum Thema Urlaub. So, ich war halt auch, ich war letzte Woche in Polen so mit dem Motorrad unterwegs,
und ja, ich hatte halt auch erstmal so ein bisschen Bedenken, so will ich eigentlich überhaupt nicht, äh, wo die Zahlen wieder ansteigen und so, überhaupt ins Ausland, äh, begeben und so, muss sagen,
es war, also speziell jetzt können nur über die Situation in in Polen berichten, wo die Zahlen auch etwa vergleichbar sind, äh wie bei uns ähm so.
Vom Verlauf her, meinst du.
Vom äh Jahr. Also jetzt ist es nicht wesentlich schlimmer oder wesentlich besser dort, sondern es ist äh von der, also sagen von der Instidenz, wie viele Leute dort Erkrankung ist, das so größtenordnungsmäßig äh wie bei uns
ja. Äh und ähm was ich aber sagen muss, also speziell
Polen wurde das Thema Maske tragen, doch
sehr ernst genommen, also ich habe in keinem Geschäft oder Tankstelle oder sonst wo Leute ohne Maske gesehen, öffentliche Verkehrsmittel weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber
ich hatte den Eindruck, auch selbst in ländlichen Regionen und so, wo wir nicht hier in Brandenburg äh unterwegs bin und tanke so äh hatte ich dann öfter schon Leute, die da einfach äh
ohne Maske zum Bezahlen, reingehen und so. Das ja, aber das ist mir dort nicht aufgefallen.
Es war auch in den meisten Gegenden mit der Gastronomie, was vor das ähnliche Handhabt, so draußen, Tische auf größeren Abstand und so und dann und.
Mit aus dem mit Airbnb oder so. Äh kann man halt auch dann sich Unterkünfte besorgen, wo man,
alleine ist und wo man eigentlich selbst noch nicht mal oft bei der Übergabe der Schlüssel oder so mit anderen Personen,
treten muss, sondern da kriegt man dann digitalen Code für irgendeinen äh Schließfach, wo dann die Schlüssel drin sind und so. Also, das ja,
das fand ich war irgendwie alles ganz akzeptabel.
Wobei, ja, was ich schon, wo ich mich schon ein bisschen unwohl gefühlt habe, äh, dann war, äh, so an manchen.
Wo sich dann viele Touristen äh sammeln, wo es mir dann doch ein bisschen unangenehm eng äh äh wurde. Ähm so, also einfach.
Viele Menschen auf einem Haufen äh und so ist erzeugt bei mir im Moment so eine gewisse Bedrohungssituation.
Ja, kann ich ganz gut nachvollziehen. Also ähm,
ja, ich war auch äh kurz in Polen habe aber jetzt da von dem eigentlichen Leben nicht so viel äh äh mitbekommen, ob ich mich da eher so auf der Countryside äh befunden habe. Ansonsten war ich so in Deutschland äh unterwegs.
Grundsätzlich geht er noch ein bisschen mehr, aber schauen wir mal, wie sich das jetzt so im Winter entwickelt. Gut, ich würde sagen, wir machen an der Stelle einfach mal einen Punkt. Pavel, ja,
dann äh
Da haben wir jetzt hier keinen Anspruch auf vollständig äh kalt, aber wir wollten uns zumindest mal zurückmelden und wie gesagt, jetzt sind wir auch gespannt auf euren äh Input und äh könnt uns gerne auf interessante Entwicklungen mal hinweisen. Und dann werden wir hier zusehen, dass wir das in irgendeiner Form.
Eingearbeitet bekommen und diskutiert bekommen und bis dahin würde ich sagen, machen wir erstmal.
Tschüs.